I feel I'm too logical to believe Jesus
is God. Before he made me million years
ago, he knows I'm going to deny Jesus.
So why would a just person create me? He
knows what I'm going to walk and then
still send me to hell.
>> It's it's your it's your girl. She says
something to me and it's I've been
thinking about it. She said my heart is
hard and I try not to be that. Like that
kind of bothered me, bro. Like
>> So you've had this conviction for over a
year. I I've I've tried to pop up a few
time on you to like get you like I got
something for you. But then I don't
believe it.
>> It's you've already been convicted of
that. As you seek him and trust in him,
he's going to hold you up, man. He's
going to carry you, bro. I don't I don't
know why, bro. Why would anybody want to
die for me in my sins and not want
anything? You know what I mean? Like
>> I've never heard nothing beautiful that,
bro. You know, it's the ultimate
sacrifice and I can't get over that. For
while we were still weak, at the right
time, Christ died for who? For the
ungodly. For one will scarcely die for a
righteous person.
>> Yeah.
>> Though perhaps for a good person, one
would even dare to die. You might think
about it. Maybe not really though, for a
good person.
>> But God shows his love for us in that
while we were enemies of God, Christ
died for us. That's the gospel. Let me
just ask you straight up, man. You
believe that Jesus is your Lord and
Savior, bro?
MG, how you doing? You're muted. All
right, you're not muted, but I just
can't hear you. Maybe you got to take
No,
>> I was muted, bro. What's up, man? How
you doing?
>> What's up?
>> I've been trying to get a hold of you
for a while, bro. I I don't know if you
remember. We had I felt like we had a
good conversation literally a year ago
from now. I've been trying to get a hold
of you, but you uh seem to like to cook
uh the Muslims a lot more than uh the
agnostics. So, I mean, basically, since
I spoke to you, I kind of been on a
journey a little bit. Uh it started off
from you and your boy with the dreads. I
feel like you guys challenged uh some of
the things I said. I I basically accused
God of uh playing games with me or just
of his creations in a way. And your
retort was basically like, you know, he
gave us a choice. It is us that's
playing games. And I was basing that off
like the story of Job. Um which I still
don't understand. Like I mean to me
based on like my understanding of things
I feel like it it I I can't tell if if
Job is it meant to be like an allegory
or is it meant to be a uh like a real
story? Like
>> what happened to Job is real?
>> Is real. Okay. So what what is the what
what's the what am I supposed to get out
of it? What what are Christians getting
out of that story? Like
>> Well, one, we get that um that God loves
us. He loved Job. He looked after him
all his life. Two, we see that we have
an enemy, a real adversary, Satan, who
really wants to attack us and cause us
to go against God and rebel just like he
did. Um, three, we see that there are
tests and calamities that that are in
our life that aren't necessarily as of a
result of our wrongdoing, but because of
um just a test for us to grow um and for
our faith to build. Like for example, if
you see Job, it says that he was
blameless, right? That he followed the
commands of God, you know, almost
perfectly basically. However, he didn't
know God for himself. He only heard of
him. He was following tradition. When
you when you get deeper into the story
and you see where Job begins to start
questioning God and asking about God and
stuff like that, and then God finally
answers him. And once he has that
conversation with God, Job then falls
and repents and says, "I sinned against
you. I did not know you. I've only heard
of you before, but now I know you.
Right? So, we see that his trial wasn't
just a game being played, but was for
his growth in his faith, and he was able
to get to know God for himself,
especially on a more intimate level as
well. And that's what calamities and
troubles will do for us. So, there's a
lot of there's a lot of different things
we can get out of Job's story.
>> Okay. Um, I just assumed I mean that
that for me um ultimately, you know,
when I was when I spoke to you and uh
your your boy, I I had some issues and
stuff with with like what happened, but
I I I let it go. And you know, I'm I'm
agnostic. I went from atheist to
agnostic. So, I'm like trying to give
God a chance. I stumbled on you because
I bought a Quran. I read the Quran, but
I just don't morally uh I don't it
doesn't fit my moral basis. I I think I
have better morality than what the Quran
and Islam Islam teaches. So my other
alternative was Jesus Christ, right?
Like I like what he teaches. You know,
like the idea that he pushes, it's a
really good idea and I think society
would be better for it if we all met uh
the standards that he pushed, right?
Regardless of whether you think he's God
or not. But for for for me is how how do
I detach Christians from him? Like
>> I have I have a serious issue with like
the modern Christians, especially like
American Christians.
>> Oh, that's what you mean.
>> Yeah. I just I just feel like they don't
uh match who Jesus was. And it it turns
>> What does that got to what does that got
to do with your walk with Jesus?
>> Let's say everybody else who claims to
be Christian was going against the
teachings of Jesus. How why would that
stop you from accurately following the
teachings of Jesus? I mean, it
shouldn't. It shouldn't.
>> It shouldn't.
>> So, you shouldn't look at people and put
them as and and make that a determining
factor of if you're going to follow
Jesus or not. No, you follow Jesus
regardless if the rest of the world
who's claiming to be followers of Jesus,
but really aren't. You could tell by
their fruits.
>> Yeah. you you make sure you follow Jesus
and you make sure that your relationship
with Christ that you're believing in him
rightly that you're holding on to his
demands demonstrating that you love him
and making sure that you're bearing the
right fruit instead of looking at other
people and saying see this is why I
won't I can't follow you Jesus because
this other person who claims to be
Christian they ain't doing right that's
that ain't that when on judgment day
that person ain't going to be next to
you when you face Jesus he going to say
what did you do did you believe. Forget
this. Ain't about me. I'm I'm talking to
you. Did you believe my words? Did you
follow my commands? Did you adhere to my
teachings? Why are you worried about
Michael and Sarah? I'm talking to you in
your life.
>> Yeah. No, that's that's a good point. As
you're saying, it's personal. Um I guess
I look at it more of a cultural thing.
Uh for me, it's uh more like a a system
that I'm trying to get myself into.
Right. That's what I'm looking for. I'm
getting old.
>> Get in the Bible. get in the in the
culture and the system of the word of
God. That's the only culture you need to
be a part of is the walking faith of
Christ. That's it. That's your culture.
H
>> how Okay, that's So, how do I get into
that without other people, right? Like,
so I would I can't get answers to some
of the stuff, right? Some things are
beyond my knowledge, right? So,
>> yeah, you other people
>> of course of course you you have
fellowship and you have fellowship. This
is then this is why you know fellowship
is important. Church community is
important.
>> Yeah.
>> But my my thing is is when you go into
fellowship don't look at certain
people's behavior as a determining
factor of you following Jesus. Cuz when
you everywhere you go well even if
you're not a you go to the club somebody
going to make you mad. You going to see
people acting up. You go to school
people going to be in class acting up.
You go what? some some political meeting
and and congressmen, they gonna be
acting up. You go to church, they going
to be acting up. There's going to be
people that do wrong. You know what I'm
saying? That's everywhere. We're humans.
But you and your walk, you you walking,
you walk according to Christ.
>> And you use your wisdom and your
discernment to test to see who you
should be linked up with and who you
shouldn't. Who's aligned with Christ and
who ain't. Use your discernment. And
Jesus says you can tell them by their
fruits. Their actions show. You make
sure your fruits align.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I don't want to judge
people. Um, you know, I'm not like
judging Christians like because at the
end of the day, right, you sinners go
sinners shouldn't go to church, right?
Like that's the idea of it. I'm not
judging them for, you know, being bad
people. It's just I just have an ick
about it, right? And I'm sure a lot of
people do because, you know, it's just,
>> you know, they got damaged by it. Yeah,
>> but your last time I spoke to you,
something your your girlfriend or
something said was that uh before me
there was a guy that basically was
agnostic and he converted and she said I
was basically like him but I had a
hardened heart which is like I think
about that. So
>> I mean I'm here for truth, you know, I'm
really trying to get the gist and the
truth of it, right? If this is real,
>> you know what I mean? Like why not,
right? And if it's not real what I I try
to live the best life that I can, right?
and get better. So, I don't know where
to go from there. I mean, say read the
Bible.
>> Read read the Bible. Try to and and and
when you're reading the Bible, read read
the gospel so that you can know what
Jesus and his character was like, what
he truly taught, what he said about
himself, and what he said about how we
are to live our lives and act out our
lives. read the gospel, read the New
Testament, and also use that as your
lens for how you connect with people,
how you, you know, cuz you're able to
make judgments. You're supposed to make
righteous judgments, not false
judgments. So, using the lens of Christ,
you use your discernment to judge who
you should fellowship with and who you
should link with.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Um, yeah. If you don't, if
you guys don't mind, I mean, say a
prayer for me. I'm I'm trying to find
God. I think, you know, for my age, I'm
trying to start a family and stuff like
that. I I want to raise a family within
like a home of God and things like that,
right? And I can't I haven't I don't
have the bug yet. And I don't know if
it's a feeling that we're searching and
last like last time I told you is I
think I'm too hyperritical and too
logical and maybe that's the
consequences of being in a liberal
democracy and
>> hyper analytical man. hyper analytical,
kind of an overinker.
>> Yeah. So, I just look at things like,
you know, like like Jesus, like I'm
like, "Okay, how can he be God and
human?" And then I hear you talk and I I
see like the Trinity like I understand
it, right? Like if I go into that world
and I use that world to like analyze it,
I don't The Bible says what it says,
right? To be Exactly.
>> That's true. It's true. I don't see how
other people are looking at it like
Trinity doesn't make sense. It makes
sense in that world. If we're to give
you that, that was a reality.
>> Yeah.
>> But for me is I am I supposed to feel
it? Is this something that I'm supposed
to
>> Not necessarily, man. Because you know
your your heart and even Jesus talks
about this how your heart deceive can
deceive you. You know what I'm saying?
Like we're not supposed to operate on
feelings right now. Feelings go into
this. However, we don't we don't base
truth off of a feeling that we get.
Otherwise, we're going to have to say
that the Mormons are in the truth
because they say that they got a feeling
in their heart and they feel that this
is the truth. Same with the Muslims.
They feel that Allah is the truth. When
they read the Quran, they get this
feeling and they know the Quran is true
because of how it makes them feel. No.
So, this is this is what God says in the
book of Isaiah chapter 1. He says,
"Come, let us reason together."
>> Right? Let us reason together. We're
able to use our minds. And this is what
the Bible says. We're supposed to love
the Lord your God with all of our heart,
that's our emotions, with all of our
soul, that's our being, our actions, our
living, and with all of our mind, with
our thinking, our knowledge, our wisdom.
We're supposed to love God in all of
those areas. Dedicate that to him. So,
with that being said, with you, you're a
very logical person. God knows that.
>> Yeah. You're not really a guy that's all
fulfilling. I'm the same way, bro. We're
we're we're logical analysts. We like
things to make sense. We like things to
be reasonable. And if it lines up, it
lines up. If it don't, we reject it.
We're similar in the same way. Use that
and test test the scriptures. See,
follow the evidence where it leads. The
evidence for the gospel, the evidence
for Jesus, his crucifixion, and his
resurrection. Look at the evidences that
backs it up and trust where the evidence
leads and put your trust. So, I like the
fact that you brought up the
crucifixion. So, for me, uh, it it like
if the crucifixion is real, right? Like,
let's say it's real, but I don't agree
with other stuff. And I agree with it.
Like, like the story of Noah's arc,
right? Like, I just can't, you know what
I mean? Like, how do I Okay, I could
believe the crucifixion is real.
Ironically, I like that could be more
realistic than Noah's arc to me. I don't
know how I could explain that to you,
but
>> okay.
>> How would I explain that away and say I
can believe in that? Am I able to do
that? Is that here's
>> So, so here's the thing. You you you
start with Jesus and then you work your
way to the other things. Let me tell you
why. Because Jesus affirms Noah's arc.
He affirms the Adam, the Genesis
stories. He affirms the stories that
Moses wrote down. He affirms all these
things. So, how can we trust them? If
Jesus truly was crucified and he truly
rose from the dead like he said he was
going to do, then he had we have every
reason to trust what he says. You know
what I'm saying?
>> This man said, "Hey guys,
>> I'm going to die.
>> I'm going to be given up. They're going
to abuse me. They're going to crucify
me. They're going to kill me."
>> However, in three days later, I'm going
to rise again from the dead. You'll see.
And he really did it.
>> Yeah. I'm I'mma believe everything cuz
say
>> for sure. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I believe everything. And at the same
time though with that cuz you can have
questions. You can inquire. In
Christianity, God invite like I just
told you, come let us know.
>> Yeah. Reason. Yeah. I like that.
>> God invites inquiry. So we can ask
about, well, how does this make sense?
What what are the views of of the of the
story of of Noah and the ark? Is it a is
it a worldly flood? How do the animals
get there? You know, and there's and if
when you read things carefully and then
you also look at because there's
evidences backing up the flood, you see
carcasses and animal remains at top of
mountains where there's where they're
land animals and stuff like that, you
know, you you see these type of things
and these evidences. You can look into
that and and God invites that. He
invites that.
>> Yeah.
>> You know,
>> okay. I didn't I didn't know I just from
um like to be fair, you know, with the
flood, I didn't look too deep into it.
But I'm just like, but how do you feed
all the animals from Australia? You're
in the Middle East. You know what I
mean? I'm looking at it at a base level,
right? So I'm not it's not a hill and a
die. All right. I give it to you, you
know, in that perspective. But I want to
believe, bro, like on the real, bro.
Like I had a, you know what I mean? I
want to give my I had a life a certain
way. And
>> I try to live through it without like
God. And everything keeps pulling me to
God in a way. You know what I mean? Like
>> and I'm glad I found you to be real,
bro. Because if how I am, I I might have
been Muslim in a way, you know what I
mean? Like
>> and I would have been like the dudes
that you talk to, bro, how like they
twist their mind. And I'm sure a lot of
those dudes are probably more logical
than us outside of that religion, right?
And other aspects, right? Some of them
are engineers and things like that.
>> Um but so should I go to a church?
Should I be careful about what church I
pick? How how or you just start with the
>> start with the Bible, bro. Start with
the Bible. And yeah, start going start
looking around for a church as well.
Like just try some out. But yeah, be
like I said, have that discernment, be
careful. Make sure like if if they're
what they're preaching, it's not
emotionalism. It's not, you know, oh,
we're just high on emotions, but they're
teaching the word. They're really
preaching the gospel. And make sure that
whatever sermon the preacher is
preaching or whatever, check in with the
gospel, making sure he's in line. You
know what I'm saying? Everything is has
to be the Bible's the foundation. Let me
um let me show you a verse, man, that uh
that you remind me of and there's been a
few people that's reminded me of this.
You're one of them. Um
but uh let's see here. So, so there was
this uh person who had a son who was um
who was sickly um and then he was
attacked by a demon.
>> And so this is what the Bible says.
>> You got no demons, brother.
>> No, no, no.
doesn't require mind.
>> You don't you don't remind me of the of
the son. You remind me of the dad. Okay?
>> So, let me show you why. Let me show you
why. So, this this is uh he said, "I'll
remind you. I ain't no demon, man." No.
So, look. So, right here, we'll start at
verse 21. It says, "Jesus asked his
father, how long has this been happening
to him? And he said, from childhood, and
it is often cast him into the fire and
into water to destroy him. But if you
but if you can do anything have
compassion on us and help us. Now watch
Jesus. He said if you can do anything
right now watch Jesus response here.
Jesus said to him if you can.
>> You think I am? Huh?
>> Yeah. Exactly. What you what you think
this is man? He said if you can. He said
all things are possible for one who
believes. And now verse 24. Immediately
the father of the child cried out and
said, "I believe, but help my unbelief."
>> Wow. I believe. I And and I I want to
trust you. I want to believe. I do
believe, but there's some unbelief in
me. I need you to help that part. Help
that part.
>> Wow.
>> And so Jesus and then goes and helps his
unbelief. if he heals his son. But only
be, look, notice, he didn't have to have
full faith in Jesus for him for Jesus to
work on his behalf. He didn't have to be
a perfect full unbeliever for Jesus to
be like, "Okay, I got you." No, he had
some belief.
>> He had some belief. Still had some
unbelief. But guess what he did? He was
bold enough to ask him, "Help my
unbelief."
>> Yeah.
>> So, in your time, I want you to have
that same attitude. You you say you want
to you say you want to believe as you
expressed it and I and I believe it you
know I believe it. Ask God ask Christ
help my unbelief. Lord you know how I
am. You know that I I like facts. You
know that I'm a I like reason. I like
logic. And I want to believe. Lord. I
want to I want to build a foundation on
you. I want to build a foundation and a
family on you. Help my unbelief. Help me
trust you.
>> That that was amazing, bro. I appreciate
it. I I've seen some of your videos
where like Muslims convert and they
>> they read the scripture and feel like
they're talking to them.
>> Yeah. I mean I I can't I mean I almost
feel like you wrote it for I mean not
you for
>> that's that's what I'm saying. I want to
believe I just don't know go about it. I
mean is there like a Christian um Shahid
or what what is it the one like Muhammad
like he's the is there one of those?
Maybe I I start with that and and you
know honestly bro it's kind of
surprisingly I feel like it's telling me
to just
>> jump and then you know what I mean let
God catch you and then see where you go
on your journey right
>> yeah yeah so this is u there's no
Christian shahada per se because that's
more so of a rehearsed a rehearsed
saying anybody can say that you know it
doesn't have to be from the heart
>> but this is what this is what I'll show
you a verse where it talks about
>> one being saved, coming to Christ. Cuz
what you're feeling is the pull of the
Holy Spirit. The Holy Spirit is pulling
you. You have this urge to believe, to
jump head in, to jump right in, to trust
in him, and let him carry you. That's
the Holy Spirit, man. Your heart is
already ready. And so, let me just show
you what uh what it says. This is
>> it's your it's your girl, your your
girl, whatever. She says something to
me, and it's I've been thinking about
it. She said, "My heart is hard." And I
try not to be that. Like that kind of
bothered me, bro. Like no, my heart
>> I want to learn. You know what I mean?
>> That's called conviction. My she's my
wife now. So, glory to God.
>> Oh, congrats, bro.
>> Thank you, man. But yeah, so when she
said that and that and that was almost
about a year ago, right?
>> I looked at the video we did just crazy.
It was October.
>> So, you've had this conviction for over
a year. The Holy Spirit has been working
with you for over a year to this moment,
bro. To this time.
>> I' I've tried to pop up a few time on
you to like get you like, "Oh, I got
something for you." But then I don't
believe it. I'm like, I'm coming with
something, but I'm like, I don't I was
like, I don't really believe what I'm
about to tell this man. I was like, I
just I'll listen to you for a little bit
and I'll head out. I'm like, you know
what? Like, I can't come to him half
ass, excuse my language, when I'm not
convinced with myself. You know what I
mean? So for a year, bro,
>> that's wild. So let me let me show you
what what the Bible says when it comes
to someone coming to the faith. This is
just one of those one of the verses,
many, but this is a a very simple common
one that I love to share with uh that
people want who want to do this. So this
is what it says. We're going to read
verse 9 and 10 or verse 9 to 11. It
says, "Because if you confess with your
mouth that Jesus is Lord and believe in
your heart that God raised him from the
dead, you will be saved. Not maybe, not
might. You do this. You confess that
Jesus is your Lord and you truly mean
it. You believe in your heart that God
raised him from the dead, that he died
for your sins and rose again on the
third day. you believe that and confess
that with your mouth in your own words
right from your heart, then you will be
saved because watch what it says. It
says, "For with the heart one believes,"
which is exactly what you're feeling.
With the heart one believes and is
justified, and with the mouth one
confesses and is saved. So, it starts in
your heart first and which is already
what you are already it's you've already
been convicted of that.
>> It starts in your heart, then it comes
out of your mouth. And once you do that
and confess it to the Lord in your own
words, from your heart, you're saved,
man. And it says, "For the scripture
says, everyone who believes in him will
not be put to shame."
Period. You believe in him, MG, he was
going to carry you. He's going to mold
you. He's going to grow you. And he's
going to give you your heart's desire as
you seek his kingdom. As you seek him
and trust in him, he's gonna hold you
up, man. He's gonna carry you,
>> bro. I don't I don't know what, bro.
>> Nah, you you about to get me, man. You
need to You need to chill,
>> bro. I'm I'm a gangster, bro. I can't I
live in Oakland, California.
>> Hey, you in Oakland? All right. We be
over there sometimes. We'll link up,
man.
>> For sure, bro.
>> How about this? After this, let's let's
exchange um uh hit my email. Let's
exchange numbers. Okay. But let but
yeah, so you can you can either you can
do it now if you want. You can do it on
your own time. Um it's up to you, man.
But I'm here with you. I'm here with
you.
>> I I believe, bro, because it's like I'm
basing it on like why would anybody want
to die for me in my sins and not want
anything? You know what I mean? Like
never beautiful than that, bro. You know
what I'm saying? Like growing up how I
grew up, nobody would ever do that for
somebody. You know what I mean? Like no,
I feel like no religion
>> answers that. And like I said, I read
the Quran. I looked into like like
Mormonism and all that and they nobody
I've never heard someone says, you know,
don't I don't want anything from you. I
did something for you already.
>> It's the ultimate Zacharite. And I can't
get over that. And your and your wife
now saying that, you know, like my heart
was hard and she was right. And I didn't
want to believe it. You know what I
mean? I wanted to come in just to attack
and not really, you know, I pride myself
on being logical and listening to the
evidence, but I I was I was deaf to it
on purpose.
>> Yeah. You know what I mean?
>> Yeah. And and that's okay. That's that's
some God got to wake us up. And and
that's that's how you know, brother. I I
don't want to I don't want to sound
cliche or nothing, but it's it's just so
true. This is how you know God loves us,
bro. Even when we are his enemies, when
we're bringing arguments against him,
trying to disprove him, he still works
on us. Still, he still works on us. Now,
I I want you to cuz what you just said
about why would somebody die for me,
man? Nobody would really do that. It's
beautiful. Watch you're you're speaking
Bible, right? You are, man, you already
speaking scripture, man. Look at this.
This is Romans 5. This is Romans 5. It
says, "For while we were still weak,
while we were still weak," meaning weak
spiritually, mentally, physically,
doesn't matter. While we were still
weak, at the right time, Christ died for
who? For the ungodly. Watch what he
verse seven says exactly what you said.
For one will scarcely die for a
righteous person.
>> Yeah.
>> Though perhaps for a good person, one
would even dare to die. You might think
about it. Maybe. Not really, though. or
a good person.
>> Yeah.
>> But God shows his love for us in that
while we were still sinners. While we
were ungodly, while we were enemies of
God, Christ died for us. That's the
gospel.
>> No, I was when the guy before you was
like, why would something about the
devil and God, like, why does God do
with us? Why would he destroy us? Right?
Like, you know, I mean, if I was God, I
would have been, man, humans, you out of
here.
That's right. Like what? What for? What?
You know what I mean?
>> Exactly.
>> So,
>> brother. Yeah. So, man, this is um man,
my heart my heart is going out this
jumping for you right now, man. Because
your honesty and the conviction that
you're you're following. You're
following the truth. Uh you said you
believe. And so, um I'll just let me
just ask you straight up, man.
>> You believe that Jesus is your Lord and
Savior, bro?
>> I do, bro. I do. I do. I can't. I can't.
I do, bro. He was my Lord and Savior,
man.
There's no other way but it, you know.
>> Do you believe that he died for your
sins and rose again on the third day?
>> I do. I do,
>> brother. MG, heaven is rejoicing, bro.
Welcome. Welcome to the family of
Christ, man. You are
>> I feel better about it.
>> Yeah.
>> I feel like I was holding something and
and denying it. You know what I mean?
>> Yeah.
>> Like I've heard the gospel enough times
in a certain way, right? like me denying
it. It's just outright. I'm playing well
I was playing with myself. So you're
right of playing game. I I accuse God of
playing games with us, but like you
said, we're the ones that are playing
games.
>> Yep. That's all in us. And so he gives
us every opportunity to turn back to
him, to answer his call, to hear his
voice, listen and follow him, and trust
in him for our salvation. Trust in his
work. There's nothing that we can do. He
did it for us. He did it for us, man.
All we got to do is trust in him. Love
him back.
>> Love him back. Relish in it. And tell
somebody else.
>> Tell somebody else, man. So,
>> brother, I I you have no idea how much
you you blessed me today, man. I'm
excited. Especially because I remember
our conversation, bro. I I remember
that, man. And so, this is a true you're
a true testimony in front of about 3,000
people. If we count TikTok, bro, there's
like 3,400 3,500 people watching all
together. You are a living testament of
what God does even with somebody who
openly publicly rejects him and how he
works in your heart even during time.
He's patient with us. He's very patient,
man. He's so patient,
>> bro. It's I'm telling you like it it is
no good on me just randomly. You know
what I mean? Just thinking about it.
I've cracked my Bible a few times and I
was going in there because I was trying
to refuel you, you know, and then I'm
like tricks on me. I'm reading the book
like God is on you, bro. This the whole
point. You know what I mean? So, I'm
sitting there, I'm reading and I'm like,
"Bro, Jesus is good. This is a good
dude." Like, I can't
>> what am I gonna say? Like, don't go to
the logic and be like, "No, I don't
follow this guy. You know, he's playing
games with him. I mean, he's telling you
turn the other cheek and, you know, I
mean, love your enemy and
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I mean? Like, how could I
deny that, bro? You know what I mean?
>> Praise God, bro. That that's insane.
>> I appreciate you being patient with me,
bro. Um,
>> hey, I I Yeah, I I appreciate you coming
coming on and being honest with
yourself, following following that lead.
I I I I appreciate it, man. I appreciate
it.
>> For sure.
>> Like I said, look, cuz we we go to
Oakland. Me and my boy, we go to Oakland
sometimes. And so,
>> um, let's let's exchange numbers. Email
me. Email me. Yeah. Be like, "Yo, this
MG, here's my number." And so, let's
exchange numbers and we'll we'll stay in
touch.
>> Sure. Well, you know what? When you guys
come up, uh, let me know, man. I got
Warrior season tickets, bro. We could
>> speaking about
>> We could We could talk to Curry. I could
tell Curry I believe in Jesus, too. You
know what I mean? Maybe only sign my
vlog or something. I think he's really
religious, so you know what I mean?
>> Yeah. Yeah. For sure. For sure. All
right. Well, I'll be I'll be looking for
that email today, man.
>> For sure, bro. I got I got you, bro. I
appreciate you, man. Um Yeah. Don't
Don't check your Instagram. I think I
was talking to you.
So like that I'm a new man. I walk I
walk with God now.
>> You walk with God.
>> It was nothing crazy because I don't
talk like that regard
like hey bro like you know it was
>> too funny. That is too funny man. I'm
I'm now I got to find the message now.
Now what you're looking for. That's
crazy.
>> But I appreciate you bro. We we'll
definitely chat some more of it because
I'm gonna have I'm gonna have questions
for sure. you are and I'm I'm here.
>> I'm here. I'm here. So, yeah, we we'll
talk, bro. We'll talk
>> for sure.
>> God bless, man. Nice talking to you
again, man.
>> Thank you, guys. See you every
>> man. Guys, wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Glory to God. Isn't our God amazing?
Isn't our God real? Isn't he active,
working on the hearts, convicting. Oh,
man. Oh my goodness. I I just I'm so
hyped right now, man. H because this He
was real, guys. He was real. I don't
know if you guys remember, some of you
guys do. I seen the some of you guys
remember him, but some of you guys who
didn't see our our video, our
conversation, he was agnostic and he was
a serious agnostic and was bringing, you
know, he had real objections against
God, you know, and was really trying to
argue against it, against him, against
the Bible, against Jesus. And over the
course of a year, my wife said
something, girlfriend at the time, said
that there was a we just had agnostic, I
think that was Charlie, Charlie, he was
agnostic, converted, believed the
gospel, was very open to the truth. MG
was hard-hearted to it, right? He was he
was hard-hearted. He was stubborn with
it. My wife said something that stuck
with him. The Holy Spirit had those
words ringing in his head for the whole
year is that we had an agnostic who
accepted Christ because he was
openhearted. Openhearted. You are you're
different from him. You're hard-hearted.
Your heart is hardened. And that stuck
with him. That convicted him. This is
why guys, we have to be patient with
people, man. We have to be patient
because God is patient. Not not just cuz
it's just simple good. No, God is
patient. He was patient with me. He was
patient with you. He was patient with
our friend MG, our new brother in
Christ. So we have to exemplify that
same patience, that same patience, that
same love. Died for the ungodly while we
were still weak, while MG was still
weak, still dead spiritually. Christ
still died for him. Christ loved him.
The Holy Spirit still working on him for
a whole year before he even truly
accepted Christ. MJ, you are a brother
in the faith, man. God bless you, man.
And I cannot wait um I cannot wait to to
touch bases with you, man. And yeah,
that's just glory to God. Glory to God.
Wow. Wow. God is so awesome. He is so
good. He's so righteous, magnificent in
all his ways, guys. Wise beyond
imagination. His love, it overflows. His
love overflows. There's nothing like our
God, the Father, Son, and the Holy
Spirit. Nothing like him. Nothing like
him. Praise God.